hallo mein name ist so kann ich hab
instagram habe ich viele leute nach teil
1 2 und 3 von böse kommentare lesen
gefragt haben hey kannst du es nicht
nochmal machen hab ich mir gedacht ich
mach das nochmal allerdings nur bezogen
auf instagram warum ja seitdem ich diese
böse kommentare lesen serie mache kommen
so viele böse kommentare über alle und
alle versuchen ins video rein zu kommen
deswegen nämlich die serie einfach dumme
instagram kommentare und lese einfach
ein paar komische dumme oder irgendwie
interessante witzige usw
instagram kommentare vor circa einer
woche dieses bild gepostet mit strom
waffel und jana wo wir den rossmann hall
gemacht haben den ich euch hier oben mal
verlinken werde oder hier
da oben ich meine dass hier verlinkt
hier
da hat little lucy 007 drunter
geschrieben du [ __ ] nicht böse gemeint
ist voll cool sogar der beste nach
meiner meinung bitte folgt mir ich
verstehe jetzt nicht wie kann man so
etwas alles in einem kommentar packen
erst du [ __ ] die alles groß geschrieben
so du sparst dir aber nicht böse gemeint
und außerdem bist du auch noch voll cool
eigentlich sogar der beste meiner
meinung nach richtig volk mir ich
verstehe es nicht wie kann man das alles
in einem kommentar packen wie kann man
so viele gefühls veränderungen haben ich
dann eines der and day dann habe ich ein
tolles bild gepostet vor ich bei dem
virtuelle bundesliga event hier in
hamburg waren da hat jemand runter
geschrieben luca bist du bayern-fan
leerzeichen leerzeichen ich bin fahre
tun
düsseldorf fortuna düsseldorf dorf ich
ich ich bin mir überhaupt muss ich da
ich glaub ich geh einfach mal weitere
kommentar unter dem bild oh scheiße er
hat ein bayern trikot gleich mal derb
und wieder witzig du hast dir abonnieren
falsch geschrieben dass wir mit doppel
angeschrieben anwalt im apple store und
hab mir eine apple watch anprobiert
anprobieren lassen an angezogen lassen
keine ahnung und da sieht man ja mein
handgelenk und übrigens ja ich hab sie
rechts um weil ich links noch eine
andere uhr um hatte die ich nicht abtun
wollte jedenfalls hatte ich die rechts
rum
hier und das ist zäher ich habe sehr
sehr dünne am gelenk also eigentlich
einen riesigen bizeps ein armes so
standardmäßig eigentlich drin wenn man
dass man hier so mit einem iphone
vergleicht geht das sei also ein halbes
iphone in etwa sage ich mal da hat der
bzw die kim darunter geschrieben die uhr
könnte man locker als fernseher an die
wand hängen ich meine groß genug wäre
sie ja das wäre so ein halbes iphone
also wenn euer fernseher so 5 x 3 cm
groß du den an die wand hängen möchtest
dann gerne aber ich möchte nicht auf so
einen großen fernseher schauen also das
ist so wie kommt man auf so ein schild
ich liebte ihn
dieses tolle city bild von mir habe ich
bei insidern post wo ich mal wieder mega
scheiße drauf außer kommt der kommentar
cool und hübsch et les eaux de mal ganz
ehrlich kann das sein dass du dein
erster bist hübsch wird mit b
geschrieben jenni 1 1555 ich kann nichts
dafür das war ich nicht einmal und
überhaupt ist das mein ding und jetzt
haltet euch fest
und ich bin fünf klasse du zwei klässler
oder 1 dieses micro leidet so viel und
ich hab schon so lange und es überlebt
schon die ganze zeit das ist eine bietet
micro hat keiner geklopft alles gut
diese strategie wie er sich recht fertig
hat mir einfach vollkommen den rest
gegeben erst so ja ich bin fünf klasse 2
klässler oder vielleicht bist du auch 1
1 klässler also erst also erst klar also
grundschul also erstklässler
dann habe ich ein bild gepostet wie ich
auf der autobahn bin weil ich da
unterwegs war und deswegen kein video
mehr machen konnte
und dann kam wieder so ein richtig
toller kommentar wo man sich denkt als
instagram user erstmal entfernen
entfernen entfernen entfernen werden
melden fonds per mail melden
like-for-like konkreter du cool r2 wie
geht's mir gut
habe gerade deine videos angeschaut was
macht
hallo antworte mal conny so richtig dumm
auch er schreibt so irgendeinen scheiß
dann so antworte mal conny wie du
antwortest du nicht so in etwas und
erschreckt einfach direkt hintereinander
so was echt mit denen wir sehen wir
gerade ein super süßes bild wo der luca
bei 5.000 km h windgeschwindigkeit im
wind stand und meine haare geflogen sind
wie sonst war es der teddybär hat dann
drüber geschrieben mensch luca hast du
wieder gefurzt po wieder stinkt wie
kommt man auf so entsteht und wie sie
davon weltkugel smiley habe ich dann
meistens bild gepostet wo ich am strand
lag und da schreibt full house drunter
wie alt bist du eigentlich von ihm ist
konnte sich als disc on crafter das ist
mir beim screenshot raussuchen gar nicht
aufgefallen so richtig naja sie schreibt
auf jeden fall erst am 21
219 geworden tommy black schreibt etwas
konkreter er ist 6 kannst du seine bio
nicht lesen ja freunde wenn ihr euch mal
meine bio anschauen würde hier nach
sechs jahre freunde sechs jahre ja
stimmt habe ich vergessen und dann kommt
der kommentar der mir wieder komplett im
rest gegeben hat es einst l 5 as boss
schreibt du bist nicht konkreter du bist
sein vater da dachte ich mir auch nur
dad kommentar hier sehen sie ein tolles
bild wo luca mit seiner matratze im pool
liegt und wir hatten unglaublich viel
spaß man sieht dass auch ich bin total
erholt
überhaupt nicht angespannt aja böse
matratze so geht es mir mit meiner
schwimmt hier robbe
ich habe die robbe roberto genannt
herzlichen glückwunsch ich schaue mal ob
ich keks habe ich habe wieder höchst
hier gefunden also die kann ich dir als
ok sega hat das noch ein kommentar
drunter von blacky mit laser luca bin
ein mega fan von dir haben alles gekauft
was im shop ist also erstmal das shop
mit sch gespielt aber dann alles gekauft
es gibt so circa 20.000 verschiedene
varianten mit farben und aufdrucken und
auf einer tasse oder wat kissen oder
keine ahnung was wenn du alles gekauft
hättest wärst du
am und ich wer reich und das bin ich
nicht und ich weiß der bank auch keine
ahnung denn ihr euch auch einen coolen
comodi oder shirt kaufen wollt dann geht
auf kontraste punkt.de mein gott war das
in das scheiße
dann war ich in bielefeld in sambia haus
wo so autos standen und da war sondern
aston martin db9 der von einer sehr
bekannten person gefahren ist deswegen
ist diese karte unbezahlbar
und da hat auf jeden fall jemand runter
geschrieben krise lp youtube manny und
ich habe gerade extra in mainz buch ja
geholt heißt money und nicht mein geld
heißt money da muss auf jeden fall muss
ich noch mal die englischlehrerin
kontaktieren her krise lp so kann das
nämlich nicht weiter gehen hier letztes
bild hier für heute ich beim tauchen
schön im pool kommentar unter von felix
3075 nicht sterben sonst kommen keine
videos mehr wenn das nicht schon genug
wäre erstmal so ja nicht sterben weil du
dann droht bis sondern einfach nur weil
dann keine videos mehr kommen aber er
gibt sich nochmal den rest er schreibt
noch aber wenn du tot bist krieg ich
deinen youtube kanal
da weiß ich auf jeden fall was hat dir
eigentlich für ein profilbild
herzlichen glückwunsch freunde ihr habt
wieder geschafft ich habe die tägliche
portion dummheit zu euch genommen durch
dieses video jetzt stellt euch gefallen
würde ich mich über eine wertung
freundin könne bei instagram folgen da
hält sich laser luca und